huh you know I it's very difficult for
me to to kind of Express exactly how I
feel about it because they're so it's
it's true you know what I mean that
people have very valid points that
there's not enough diversity you know
what I mean I and I can't say disagree
with that but you know I can't say I
know enough about the entire situation
to say oh well you know this wasn't fair
that wasn't fair but it's usually not
fair so I mean do you think women gonna
get a fair deal in entertainment in
general compared to the competitive guys
I don't think women get a fair deal in
anything compared to guys yeah I mean
there's so many it's it's it's really
hard to it's it's a difficult subject
because obviously I'm gonna have my own
opinions and I don't want to offend
anybody but it's it's obvious that you
know we've had to women and minorities
have had to fight for you know trying to
get equal opportunities for for ages so
I mean you know how can you not agree
back to the tool what what would the
fantasy in Mariah Carey that's different
from 2003 where do you think you are now
as an artist compared to compared to
back then
well 2003 was a very was kind of like a
was it was a cute tour of Ike if that
makes any sense it was it was the way we
art directed it and the ensembles and
stuff like that so you know and it was
before I had done the emancipation of
Mimi which now adds so much to my
catalog and you know equals MC square
and the other albums that followed so
you know there there's a lot more I had
a lot of material then but there's a lot
more material
now and a lot more songs that I kind of
have to do because of how big the songs
were but I don't know I think I'm just a
lot more comfortable maybe on the stage
it's it's it's uh I've become a little
bit more comfortable with in my own skin
if that makes any sense
definitely it's much more fun when you
just talk to the audience I mean like
most people don't have the same
relationship with their fans where I
mean I'll say that and maybe I'm wrong
maybe other people do but I have I kind
of just like talk to the fans when I'm
on stage as if they're at home with me
because you know I have to be a little
more excited because you don't want to
bore them like you're sitting around
watching TV but I mean it's it's for me
it's it's about connecting with the fans
the other American who everyone is
talking about in Europe I'm sure you
know is Donald Trump have you been
following what's going on with with his
world do you think he'd be a good
president for the United States on the
on the world stage
I'd like to abstain from that question
do you think Hillary Clinton is someone
who would be a good a good model for
United States on the world stage
yeah I'm just an entertainer but you
know I am a fan of Hillary I'm a fan you
know it's of course I'm a fan of Hillary
of course I would love to see a woman
president you know I don't feel like
it's appropriate for me to go on and on
and a tangent because I'm just an
entertainer I'm not a political analyst
but you know hopefully that's enough for
you to understand that I'm saying
something positive in the UK for us that
those those fans in Waiting those those
six venues what would you say to them
about what they can expect I would just
say expect to be I would hope that they
come expecting to really have a
connection with me because that's the
most important thing I mean music is
something that brings people together
and so I'm hoping that they feel that
connection through that and just through
being in the room together you know
thank you so much yes snuck in the
political on